ciao a tutti io a breve finalmente ne
andrò in vacanza grazie al cielo e
recentemente mi stavo guardando un po di
video che avevo fatto in passato
così solo a casa in maniera anche un
pochino triste stava davanti al computer
e ridevo di me e non la capisco perchè
voi ridete
[Musica]
e fra questi ce n'è uno in particolare
che mi è rimasto qua perché appena ho
finito mi sono incominciate a venire un
sacco di idee per poterne fare un altro
ed è una cosa che procrastinato il nodo
adesso perché la domanda rimane sempre
la stessa
se i motivi che non si sarà il materiale
se i modi di dire fossero reali sport
non sono facevo più
e così ho accettato la scuola
tocca mai scappato alla kakà prendila
sei bella da morire io perderò
ti presento culo e camicia ciao scusa di
far dire
cosa questo noi ea collassata capito ma
tutte sempre agresta quei soldi che ti
do raggiungiamo un pochino di olio di
comitiva per un batte la scopa tela
chiamatela limonate la nomina smettila
di canzoni che abbiamo fuori che non è
vero non sono matto non lo sono ancora
ceca qual è quello un tipo tosto senza
peli sulla lingua
mi sono fatto il mazzo guarda ho preso
un granchio dai su abbassa le anime nord
del freno discorso il cazzo
praticamente in fiamme spalla si va
[Musica]
il culo alla balena basta con questa
bandiera mattutino
la smith era intento ristorante monte
della pizza
che la dura per un bel no io prendo il
fungo il gioco non vale la candela
metti la testa pronto a una cosa
solamente stupida che volevo dirvi
allora esiste una cosa meravigliosa il
carnevale pulcinella arlecchino
compagnia bella ecco cosa facevano i
miei nonni con le loro figlie da piccoli
a carnevale creavano halloween
fondamentalmente mia mamma ha 13 anni ha
creato resta cioè questo questa
divertimento di mia madre per il suo
carnevale e mia madre contro halloween
perché te lo credo lei faceva questo
carnevale quindi molto probabilmente non
lo sarebbero come gli argento dario
argento al sergente secondo me mangiano
nelle bare ecco e credo che anche mia
madre i miei nonni facessero la stessa
cosa
niente non è niente dai secoli con un
festeggia il carnevale sono molto solo
[Musica]
tu sei la mia unica amica